- So hi, everybody.
My name is Sara.
And we are going to play a game.
What do guys think
this game is called?
- Simon Says.
- How about we call it...
- Red light, green light.
- It's called The Shopping Game.
How many of you like
to go food shopping?
You do?
How many of you guys like to
pick out things and put them
in the cart?
Me, too.
So today, you get to pick
out things and put them
in the cart.
And there are three rules.
Rule number 1--
So this game is a nice
way of illustrating
all the different
choices that we
have to make in our everyday
lives, which actually have
big implications for
the way that we eat
and our diets and
our long-term health.
And so in this case, we took
a whole bunch of choices.
And we said to the
kids, we're going
to put some rules
on those choices.
You can have five things,
but you get one treat.
And you can't repeat
any of your choices.
And surprisingly,
there was actually
a fair amount of
variation among kids
who were roughly the same age.
All right.
Well, I think we
should go shopping.
What do you guys think?
- Yeah.
- Grab your baskets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So how does this little game
relate to the broader research
that we do here at Harvard
at the Radcliffe Institute?
So number one, we are constantly
faced with food choices
in the environments
in which we live.
And it's more often the
case that the food choices
are unhealthy and not healthy.
Particularly if you're
in a state or a city
where you have a large
low-income or minority
population, those
populations tend
to be at higher
risk for poor diet,
at higher risk for obesity, and
lots of conditions associated
with excess body weight.
And so there's a real interest
in thinking about, what
are the things that we can
do to change the broader
environment to encourage
people to be healthier?
Can you tell me, of these
items, which is the treat?
- The soda.
So one of these things
is a treat, Cecelia.
Which one is the treat?
What is that again?
- Juice.
- In life, one of the ways
that research becomes important
is, when we do put
rules in society--
like, for example, saying that
we're going to make beverages
cost more money if they
have added sugar, or saying
that we're going to put
calories on restaurant menus--
when we add those
sorts of rules,
does that either change
the way consumers behave,
or does that change the
way industries behave?
Why is juice a treat?
- Because it has--
because it has sugar.
- And why is soda the treat?
- Because soda
has lots of sugar.
- So let me ask you a
question, if you were at school
and they served
juice all the time,
would you drink
juice all the time?
- Yes.
- You would?
You would drink it all the time?
Is that a good thing
or a bad thing?
- Bad.
- That's a bad thing.
So when we think about
different examples of, is there
evidence to actually support
changes in our broader food
environment that are actually
having an impact on our health,
the answer is yes.
And so if we start
with beverage taxes,
Berkeley was the first
US city to do this.
And what they've shown is that
about a year after the tax
has been in place, that people's
purchasing of those items
has dropped by about 10%.
Sugary beverages are one
of the leading sources
of added sugar in our diet.
And they are huge
contributors to weight gain.
They also cause dental
caries, or cavities.
Another example is on
the restaurant setting.
And so because there is this
federal rule now which says,
if you're a large
chain restaurant--
so if you have more than 20
outlets around the country--
you have to post
calories alongside price.
What the research shows
is, the impact of that
is not that you and I
make different choices
at the point of purchase.
There's a little bit
of that, but not much.
The impact is that restaurants
are changing the amount
of calories on their menu.
So for example, if you look
across these large chain
restaurants, the
average calories
in newly introduced
menu items has gone down
by about 70 calories or
12%, which may sound small,
but that difference
can actually really
have a big impact, particularly
because, on any given day,
a third of kids and a
third of adolescents
and a third of adults are
eating in these restaurants.
And so if you're carving
out calories and not
relying on people
to make choices,
you are going to have
more of an effect.
- Thank you for playing.
- You're welcome.
- Thanks for playing
the shopping game.
- Thanks, Mom.
- [LAUGHS]
- Bye.
- 20 M&Ms, that's it.
- OK.